dizaines de victimes du conflit en syrie
et cela sans prendre un avion et s'en
allait en syrie pour la première fois en
fait les fondateurs de ce projet unique
ont accepté que leur histoire soit
raconté le reportage de yannick dumont
baron
il a tout l'air de médecins comme les
autres mais c'est aussi un homme en
mission l'un des rares à faire partie de
réseaux qui soutient le peuple syrien
dans une guerre qui a fait plus de 90
morts
ayoye n'aggrave dame je veux les aider
chaque jour chaque heure chaque minute
des oui non si essentiel à cette mission
c'est le téléphone que ce canadien
d'origine syrienne porte à sa ceinture
un appareil qui ne doit jamais
s'éteindre raté un appel pour écouter
une ville qui initie au disque en crise
on disposera d'ici gens torturés truc
tout simplement parce qu'ils cherchent
la liberté et le monde entier qui leur
tourne le dos c'est très triste ac
parfois je me sent désemparé valaisanne
deux années de conflit en pratiquement
détruit le système de santé de la série
500 frontières accuse les troupes
gouvernementales d'avoir tirer sur les
ambulances bombarder les hôpitaux et
persécuter le personnel médical
conséquence pour halle est la plus
importante ville du pays le nombre de
médecins est passé de 5000 à seulement
ne sont que 5 en amérique du nord dont
deux canadiens à se rendre presque
chaque jour sur cette ligne de front
virtuel ils sont tous d'origine syrienne
ils vont prêter main forte à des
compatriotes médecins et infirmières
ce réseau qui soigne surtout des civils
dépend d'une connexion ethernet
clandestine
les alertes arrive par messages textes
envoyés entre deux comptes secrets
elles peuvent entrer à n'importe quelle
heure que le médecin soit au chevet d'un
patient ou sur une plage des possibles
une connexion est établie avec un site
le destin comme celui ci le d4 en
activité dans un secteur du pays
contrôlé par l'armée syrienne libre
nous ne préciseront pas où sont
installés ces caméras web afin de
protéger ceux qui les utilisent
c'est un système tout simple et bon
marché qui permet un suivi médical
autrement est possible la zone de guerre
dès janvier des infirmières syrie ont
accès aux conseils de médecins et
amérique du nord salamalecs ont l'image
est parfois mauvaise la connexion
ethernet fait défaut le docteur secure
parvient finalement à joindre son
contact en syrie
aujourd'hui il faut s'assurer que la
facture de patients guérissent bien il
s'est cassé le bras lorsque nos bus a
détruit sa maison est attaquée c'est une
consultation de routine
d'autres sont bien plus graves la
plupart des cas sont liés à la guerre
des gens qui ont besoin de soins
intensifs immédiatement cette ligne de
front virtuel maher secure l'a imaginée
après une visite en syrie où il a été
très touché par le sort des enfants
qt casino times on ne sait jamais quand
les besoins seront présents on ne sait
pas quand aura lieu le prochain massacre
on a pensé à la façon dont se déroule
cette guerre on s'est dit qu'on devrait
se rendre disponible en tout temps
ces 24 heures sur 24 we saw that we need
to mars est avérée depuis le début de
l'année leurs efforts ont permis de
sauver une trentaine de vie et
d'apporter un peu de courage aux rares
infirmières et médecins qui pratiquent
toujours en syrie au péril de leur vie
je ne me sens plus seul et je sens qu'on
appuie ça me redonne espoir
aa fait le dr secure a tellement cette
cause à coeur qu'il est prêt à traverser
le canada pour une seule soirée
il en profite pour tenter de convaincre
d'autres expatriés d'offrir leur appui
et de l'argent si possible lives and
medical technology
oui je laisse les termes médicaux côté
j'essaie de toucher leur coeur je leur
demande d'imaginer que c'est leur fille
leur fils ou encore leur mère ou leur
père qui se retrouve dans une telle
situation
imagine décision
le message semble avoir été bien reçu
300 mille dollars ont été amassés en une
seule soirée et à comment va une dizaine
de médecins dont des européens espèrent
rejoindre cette ligne de front virtuelle
dans les prochaines semaines pour
l'instant c'est le quotidien qui
rattrape maher secure l'espère bien
retourner en syrie pour une cinquième
fois en douze mois
une autre façon de se rapprocher de ce
peuple qu'il veut tenter d in it
provides - énergie je veux plutôt leur
apporter de l'énergie les encourager en
retour ils vont m'encourager
ce n'est pas la place que pleurer mais à
chaque fois que je quitte la série
une fois dans l'avion je sens le groupe
fois sur mes épaules et là je fonds en
larmes
mais